so we've covered the first second
and now the third jose brewery
out of the twenty joe spurries bushiro
ski
now many people ask me the same question
world over do you look behind
on the on the third joe screen
the answer is i was told by sighted
sensei no
i don't know how true it is i've only
heard it once but
i'll tell you again i've told it many
times perhaps on
films cytosins said
there was a blind man and he's walking
along with his stick and
children used to poke him and
pester him from behind and and
because he was blind what's the point in
looking behind you're not going to
see them and he would just thrust his
stick at them
to ward them off
so whether that's true or not
i have my doubts but
it just it's a reminder to me that you
don't look behind
if anybody tells you this then i'm sorry
but
they're incorrect because uh
look at look on the side of senses
videos that's that's the best way
and if i'm wrong then i apologize but
always refer
i do if i'm in doubt always refer back
to the psychosensitive videos
there's other abundance out there okay
usher those key
the pros and the cons
don't look down this i i say this every
time don't look down and see where your
joe is
if you're a competent person just put
your joe down if you're in a hedgehog
it's going to be in the right place it
doesn't matter if it's
doesn't matter if it's out a little or
not
on the third it needs to be out a little
bit
remember if a blind person is doing this
he's not going to thrust it while it's
on the
inside is he he's only going to thrust
it when it's on the outside
so stand in here tell me put your
inside your hand being in front of you
in front of you
just move it to the side just a little
this hip is back i'm going to contradict
what i said before when i said don't
come square i want you to come square
but
to touch that with the fingers
out to the side comes round
the knees soften but the pelvis taps the
same as
at the end of a can cut same as a
first very can cut
that the hand pushes forward
as you tap the pelvis
it makes the joe sit under
your forearm
just step back
the other question i get asked is where
do you thrust to
you thrust if you're on your own you
thrust to the pit of your stomach
so there's your navel
and about here the pit of the stomach
the bottom of the stomach that gives you
a guide
of where you're striking if you strike
lower than that
you know you might miss something
so
foreign
of course i'm breaking it down for you
to see
this mustn't cover the end
but you use the fingers here
and then take hold
thrust
not too low the pit of your stomach
suzuki
kai shizuki
kashizuki
foreign
fish
hmm